foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey solution
broadcasting from the PODS moving and
storage Studio this is the Ramsay show
it's where America hangs out to have a
conversation about life specifically
your money
your relationships your work they're all
tied together we're thrilled that you
are here on Ken Coleman joined by George
Campbell with random personalities and
we are your guides this hour the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's
toll-free
888-825-5225 George are you warmed up
I'm ready to go you're ready to go we
had a big day today big night we'll talk
about that later but you've done your
vocal exercises I didn't do that but is
that how you do it I think you're ready
now I'm good let's go to Elena in Grand
Rapids Michigan Elena how can we help
oh yes hi I am a big fan of the show uh
Mr uh I just finished the proximity
principle and that was super helpful oh
thank goodness
whoever wrote that book is a genius
please yeah
exactly where I was at the moment
is I am a single uh single lady I am
debt free
nice I have a four months I have a four
month emergency fund
and I just relocated to Grand Rapids
about two years ago so I kind of
reestablished myself uh and got a new
job last year I made about 35
000 last year uh it will be a little
more this year my question is uh since
I'm single right now I am renting a
basement apartment and it's meeting my
needs right now as far as just relocated
and
getting back on my feet I was just
curious what your thoughts are I would
love I'm I'm torn to whether if I should
move into a more uh functional
Apartments
and or put a down payment on a house and
I guess the reason why I'm going back
and forth is just because I am single
and I really don't have anybody in the
picture or plan on getting married to
really like help me maintain a house
uh but I also know that a house can be
an asset for you
and so I'm kind of torn of making
monthly rent payments or maybe start out
making uh getting an apartment and
working towards until I find something
that I'm looking for for a house payment
cool so what are you paying for that
basement room right now
uh so the basement rent right now is
475. that's hard to beat in today's
America all right and what would rent be
probably closer to 900 to 1000 for a one
bedroom
yeah between 800 to 1200 okay
and do you know your monthly take-home
pay out of that 35k
uh it's about
close to about 2500 three grand okay
that helps me yeah I absolutely want you
to be a homeowner Elena and it may be a
little further out you've got that
emergency fund so your next step would
be to start saving up a down payment I
would aim for 10 20 is even better to
avoid that private mortgage insurance
but that would be my next goal and it
may not be a year or two from now and
you may say hey you know what I'd like
to be have a little more of my own space
I'm going to move into an apartment that
might mean getting your income up a
little bit what are you doing for work
right now
I work in customer service at a bank
here in the Grand Rapids area and I'm
also I just uh am starting my own
virtual assistant business which is very
much an infant stage so I obviously want
to do that full time but I need that to
I need to get that up to where it
matches or surpasses my current income
before I walk away or you know get to a
point to where I can maybe just go
part-time so are you wanting to be a
virtual assistant
yes so you could go do that tomorrow and
probably make more than you're making in
customer service right
I'm just now starting my business so I'm
just now starting to get up and running
to where I can't really
I mean I am applying for a virtual
assistant uh gigs but right now it's not
to the point where I can step away or go
part-time from my full-time job
okay
well as far as getting your income up
that would help with the rent I would
like that rent to be no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay so that
would be my goal stay in the basement
until we get the income up once we get
it up and it's about 800 bucks turns
into a quarter of our take-home pay
let's go rent and in the meantime let's
start saving up that down payment and
have a goal look at maybe a condo or
town home you don't need to get a giant
home right now but even a condo or
townhome could be a good future goal in
the area that you live in and figure out
all right it's 250 I want to put down 10
that's 25 000. how can I get my income
up in order to save that up in the next
few years
okay that sounds good I am looking like
at seeing what town Town Homes would be
and that's kind of like the route I
would kind of like to go but like what
I've found so far the town homes are
only renting right now and so if I did
go to the Town Home Route I would kind
of like to like
buy it does that make sense oh sure
absolutely and that was my my first two
homes were town homes and it's a great
option you do have to consider a
slightly higher HOA fee but it's not a
bad time to get in touch with a real
estate Pro you can do that
ramseysolutions.com and they can help
you navigate the search and dial that in
to at least give you a picture
financially of what this looks like for
the next few years
right I am in contact with an agent with
Churchill Mortgage uh they are they have
a couple of offices located up here so I
am in contact with an agent through them
uh so I am in process of working with
one of the Churchill Mortgage agents
cool and check out our friends at belay
uh they're they're a company that
specializes in Virtual assistants and
they can connect you to an employer and
you may not need to wait to start a
business to jump into virtual assisting
so that's why I encourage you to not
wait for that but go after it if you're
ready to make that jump yeah and then
the only thing I would add too I'm ready
I I and I would add to George has given
you the money answer and you need that
you need to understand that formula but
I would just really encourage you to
um kind of dig a little bit and there's
this natural desire that humans have for
Progress right we want to make make up
the move and keep moving but really just
dive in and say what's driving you know
my impatience and and I need to get
control of that and and again you're not
out of control but the idea here is for
you to go this is really a Temptation
for me and I kind of see this I want
this I hear this I watch this and it's
kind of driving me and it's like you
want to stay within the formula of the
numbers yes those are your guard rails
but also just just be content
contentment is not complacency and I
think sometimes that's the Temptation
you're doing great Elena you're an
absolute rock star you got a brilliant
future ahead of you
be patient be patient wait
wait
wait you know it's always worth it
George on the other side of that yeah we
live in a culture that just wants to go
go go go but when we slow down we make
better decisions yeah absolutely true
Elena thank you so much for the call hey
George and I are here for you we got to
take a quick break the phone number
triple eight eight two five five two two
five don't move more of the Ramsay show
coming up
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more first
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey show a
conversation about your money your work
and your relationships
so excited that you're with us the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five
two two five George camel uh my co-host
colleague uh distinguished gentleman wow
um keep going thanks yeah I ran out I
need to have a list next
oh yeah absolutely we've been known to
uh do dinner with the wives that's crazy
it's largely for them it's yes we don't
talk to each other we're just the eye
candies that's all we're there for well
I've never been called that and never
will again
um but we are here for you George is
going to take your specific money
questions and I'm here to answer any
work related questions your income is
your greatest wealth building tool how
do we do work that we're really good at
work that we enjoy that yields a whole
lot of great results including income
and impact I'm here to take any of those
questions today we're here for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Rachel joins us in Knoxville
Tennessee Rachel how can we help
hi guys can you hear me I can loud and
clear what's up
all right so me and my husband were just
talking about possibly living in a
different state and the one that we both
kind of were interested in living in was
Alaska and where we went to Tennessee
that's a huge move yeah so we were just
wondering if that sounds crazy is there
any Financial guidelines that you have
for that uh anything against it for it
any any unbiased advice you could give
us well
George I want to jump in before we even
get to the money recommendations on
moving because I'm sure we both get some
opinions on that done that a lot
um
why do you think it's crazy
or are you wondering if anyone else
thinks it's crazy that was really the
first question so we we are both of our
families would think it was crazy all
right so they think it's crazy
but you and your husband don't think
it's crazy in fact now you probably have
a different adjective I want you to pick
the adjective just for fun you're not
locked into this what's the adjective
that you would use for moving to Alaska
if it's not crazy it is
fun exciting yes potential wow that's
great I think that's fantastic
so the reason your family doesn't like
it
is because they're sad
because they're scared
maybe they're confused
because you pursuing this fun exciting
Journey
is filtered to them as
you're leaving us
you are abandoning us you are robbing us
of time to see you and the kids and
everybody else do you see how it's
completely different
translation for them when they hear this
yes yeah all right but here's the deal
would you rather disappoint them by
moving to Alaska and having this awesome
fun Journey that you and your husband
feel that you guys are meant to do
uh or would you rather resent them by
not leaving
and always wondering what could have
been
what would you rather choose when you
put it like that that's eye-opening yeah
that that changes it the narrative
completely there we go I'm glad our
opinions won't sway you then you you
want to do this I think people who run
marathons are crazy they love it and
they enjoy it and so it's a it's a great
analogy of what's right for you may not
be right for someone else so I'm all for
this move you asked about the financial
details there are a few steps you can
take to step into this without a bunch
of fear but instead excitement you've
done the homework so are you guys debt
free
we are dead free yes and we have um yeah
we do have about ten thousand dollars
just in um in Investments uh 14 000 in
emergency funds four thousand dollars in
the bank for business thinking funds so
yeah that gives me great peace about
this move now there are going to be
moving expenses so make sure that's set
aside that's not an emergency so let's
set that aside as well and begin
researching you know what what's the
quality of life going to be like what do
we need to know about the weather uh
commutes schools
um you know areas of crime what's the
cost of living going to be have you
looked into all that
no that isn't that is exactly why I
called you we were we didn't didn't
consider that at all other than just
where do we want to live and where can
we find a job great and another resource
for that of course is people who
actually have lived in Alaska or
currently live in Alaska so that would
also be something I can talk with
someone face to face versus just reading
a Blog about Alaska is going to be more
helpful especially in the city that you
plan on moving to so are you do you have
jobs lined up there or are you working
remote
that's where that's what we were looking
into is where we could find a job so
that that would be the first step
absolutely okay so let's start there
let's start with what we currently have
skill and experience in right so we're
going to start the search there this is
what we are doing this is what we can do
and we begin to look and see because you
just I've been to Alaska I spent six
months there one time working on a a a
campaign and it's a very spread out
remote so things are very concentrated
if you're in the Anchorage area you know
you're going to have a pretty good
representation of just most mid-sized
cities that's what that job economy
looks like in Anchorage it is very very
different in the outskirts of Alaska do
you understand what I'm saying are you
guys thinking Anchorage uh Suburbia of
Anchorage are you thinking like
outskirts these smaller towns where
we're flying a plane just to get
anywhere
where we don't know the area at all we
were thinking Anchorage and then
figuring out once we got there all right
um this is not related to job but this
is related to this whole decision you
guys need to probably go spend more time
there just on vacation like scouting
trips before we make this move I love
that yeah that you're that you're
thinking about this adventure and you're
taking this season of life you're debt
free so you can do it but I got to tell
you something this needs to be let's go
spend a week there let's go see three
cities uh let's let's look at the list
that I just told you to create and and
let's dive deep and and begin to maybe
apply and just go through some
interviews just to see we've got to get
our feet wet on this deal this is not a
jump in all the way I don't like that at
all because this dream this dream could
become a nightmare pretty quickly
so we're looking at what is it really
like there
and what is the job opportunity so we're
sustaining ourselves and able to fund
our adventure that's first and foremost
and then we begin to put the plan
together George I I yeah boy I don't
like just going wee wee that's it feels
like we wouldn't do that we wouldn't do
that that's why we called to ask
questions I know but I want to challenge
you on that let's let's get ourselves
you know very informed this is the stage
that we call uninformed optimism like
when you start something new you're just
so excited about it and you don't have
enough research to even be pessimistic
about it and the next stage is informed
pessimism where you start to feel a
little overwhelmed because you started
doing the research like oh this is a lot
and so there's going to be a journey of
ups and downs and a lot of emotion
around this and you may end up not
moving you may go visit and say it's a
fun place we love to visit there once or
twice a year we're going to stay planted
in Knoxville for now that might happen
are you guys homeowners right now
no no we're not okay you're renting so
consider do we have to break a lease is
there a fee involved with that should we
wait until the lease is up so there's
some logistical pieces when it comes to
housing you want to think about here too
what do you guys do for a living
electrician and dietitian
okay well I like the electrician play I
think that's going to probably be very
much uh excuse me there'd be a lot of of
opportunity there
uh but you've got some work to do on
dietitian and what that may or may not
look like there but an electrician in
the trades in Alaska I like this I like
this a lot I told my husband I was like
he probably would be able to find a job
before me yeah yeah all right well we've
got a great resource for you at
ramseysolutions.com how to move to
another state it's got all the stuff
I've been mentioning I'll make sure
Austin gets you a link to that you can
also just uh search for that on your
favorite search engine but that will
start to give you a checklist of the
things you need to do the homework ahead
of you in research and make sure you've
got a job lined up before you make this
move the last thing you want is for this
to turn into a real stressful situation
George I want to get them off to a head
start let's check one thing off the list
I gotta talk to our friends at PODS
moving and storage yes how do you even
think about going from Knoxville
Tennessee to Alaska without calling
myself
huh one less thing to work they got the
stores they got the moving in other
words they take care of your headache
that was good Ken nice so smooth well
I'm excited about this Alaskan Adventure
hope it works out Rachel yeah send us
some salmon can you do that I don't
they're just on Ice maybe on Ice I don't
know how long it keeps but I know what
does keep the Ramsay show keeps on his
quick break don't move
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life specifically your money
your work your relationships all of
those areas of our lives are completely
connected and we want to give you hope
to be able to win in all three areas and
George camel is my co-host I'm Ken
Coleman with Ramsay personalities and uh
big night tonight folks the lobby is a
zoo out there I don't know what you're
doing uh wherever you are what what Big
Show you got uh tivoed or what you're
watching on Netflix maybe a Dixie
Stampede a little dinner and
entertainment maybe I don't even know
what that is feels like that's something
you do in Pigeon Forge four people out
there understand okay great and uh so
but tonight if you don't have any big
plans uh you need to join us for our
live stream event it's called Building
Wealth and it's happening tonight at 7
00 p.m we're going to show you how you
can still make progress on your goals
build wealth and have peace with money
even in this nutty economy
so you don't have to live with money
being tight you don't have to settle for
that during this event you're gonna hear
from Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz George
Campbell John deloney and me we're going
to help you set goals and create margins
so you can begin Building Wealth this
year don't miss the live stream again
it's tonight at 7 pm Central George that
means 8 P.M Eastern if you're keeping
score 7 P.M Central Mountain Time
Pacific they never get any love they
never get it's always Central and
Eastern you know it's a very good point
it's a very well Pacific gets it Eastern
Pacific you know but anyway we got 7 P.M
Central 8 Eastern you can register for
free at ramseysolutions.com wealth
that's the website
ramsesolutions.com
wealth ramseysolutions.com you don't
want to miss it's going to be a lot of
fun and we've got a bunch of people in
the lobby today that are here earlier
these are what we would call the early
birds yeah they're real excited they are
excited they get bonus points do they
all right George will hand those out on
the next commercial break he had one guy
go yes he's excited yeah he's excited
um all right George so uh you're on the
social media yes you do the social media
I do that and uh you had a post recently
that I that I think is very interesting
so it's very irrelevant recently for the
very first time in my in my life went to
Bucky's now if you've heard about
Bucky's it is a gas station chain that's
been Regional they're spreading now and
I went to one in Athens Alabama for the
first time heard a lot of Buzz about it
people are freaking out and I'm going I
don't understand it's a gas station like
how can this be life-changing yeah no no
before we go any further when I want
people to fully understand the hype
around this if because we have a lot of
people listening from a lot of places
watching from a lot of places
this thing is certainly in the South
Southeast has taken on like this crazy
thing kids are buying my kid I have
three teenagers all right their friends
are showing up at my house with Bucky
backpacks Bucky sweatshirts I mean it is
now they have one they have won the
brand War oh yeah like it is no longer a
roadside convenience store gas station
this is an experience for people well in
Christmas time there was all these
inflatable Bucky beavers out in yards
yeah Santa's out Bucky's is in yeah
something about Bucky and and the Beaver
but really it's about uh the the culture
of the entire place now full disclosure
I've not been in one but everybody else
in my family has and so I've heard
firsthand how unbelievable it is from
the way it looks the way it feels the
stuff on the shelves I mean uh one of
our co-workers here got introduced me to
a bag of beaver nuggets legendary I
didn't know what a beaver nugget was
caramel coated Corn Pop snack there it
is that's what it is so Ken I had a bad
attitude going into this yeah you were a
little snarky weren't you yeah it was I
was like let's see what's so special
about this it was special Ken I walked
in there what was special about it first
of all the employees are incredible
they're happy to be there they're doing
a great job the place is clean it's
amazingly stocked they're cooking up
fresh brisket they have the most amazing
selection they've got you know Bucky's
branded snacks that I'm just learning
about for the first time it was it was
like an adult Disney World
and uh even better Ken here's what where
you come into this
on my way out I see a sign that they're
hiring and it was amazing let's put that
sign up that they've got out there and
here's what's amazing no experience
necessary the lowest paying job at
Bucky's is 17 bucks the general managers
make 150 to 225
thousand yeah I heard you wow no
experience necessary they got a 401k 100
match up to six percent three weeks paid
time off immediately you can use it cash
at role at Healthcare they've got
part-time jobs you get an extra two
bucks for the overnight shift and it
just made me go there is hope for for
the job you know economy in America
today well you know I'm glad you're
bringing this up because first of all
folks the job economy is really hot
unemployment's back down to 3.5 percent
wages at an all-time high I just looked
at the sign it said the car wash manager
makes 125. thousand 125 000 to be the
car wash manager at Bucky's
stop griping
I can't get ahead go to Bucky's and be a
car wash manager
well Ken there's a lot of that that's
the lesson well there's an anti-work
mentality out there there's very
pessimistic very cynical towards the
idea of employment in general and when I
walked in that I went these people are
excited to be here they've got a great
culture number one that's right and
great pay great benefits and they're
doing work that matters that's exactly
right by the way let's let's talk about
that
when we say work that matters and then I
talk about this all the time with the
king Coleman I'm the work guy here at
Ramsey right and I just believe that you
were created to contribute to your work
in other words what's the difference
that you want to make in the world
what were you born to do you you're just
hardwired with Talent you got a heart
there's a type of work a function you
love to do you care about making a
difference in the world and and we've
made we've made like success in work
this unicorn with wings
and it's like how can I join myself and
the fact of the matter is some of those
people are really in their dream job and
it's not because it's sexy or that it
pays a million dollars it's just they
really enjoy showing up every day and
they enjoy it while they're there
and they can see a result
that they care about and no experience
necessary means I didn't need to go get
a four-year degree because of the
pressure from parents and Society to
then have to get a job pays 30 grand
that I'm miserable in this is the trend
of 2023 right here what's that companies
are now hiring
for skill not for qualification in other
words they're going to hire you based on
can I train you to be the car wash
manager at Bucky's not I have a degree
in automobile cleansing
there it's it's less about the degree
companies are dropping degree
requirements and they're going we're
going to hire for skill in other words
what they're really saying is if we feel
you have the Raw Talent and you get some
good character we're going to train you
to have the skills you need this is the
new trend folks and and it should be
encouraging for those of you out there
who feel like you're dealing with
imposter syndrome you got some doubt
because you go I can't make the kind of
money I want to make because I didn't go
to a to a to a steak and Sizzle School
I I didn't go to an Ivy League school or
I didn't go to the biggest school I
don't even have a degree at all Ken well
guess what the playing field is being
leveled companies are saying we just
want good people we'll train them how to
do the job and Bucky's is an example
they're saying it in their ads they're
going no experience required what what
isn't that lovely well I think companies
are now hiring for character competency
that's it and they're going we can hire
they yeah we can teach you how to do the
job that's fine but do you have the
people skills do you have the soft
skills the hard skills all those pieces
coming together to then create a job did
you get your car washed by the way I
didn't we were in a rush it was in and
out I got some brisket got out of there
but man I wish I I could have stayed for
hours to be honest well and what people
need to understand is is what a quality
company looks like and sounds like it
feels like and this is it the people are
happy the environment is nice there's a
direct correlation between happy excited
enthusiastic people and a clean
energetic environment you could ate a
meal off that bathroom floor it says a
lot to me that George Campbell the
George camel that I've known for quite
some time bought brisket at Bucky's in
fact that's my biggest surprise of 2023
so far and I I dare say at the end of
2023 you'll still be at the top of the
list I've been described as bougie you
know and so people go you're gonna get
brisket from a gas State no don't look
at it like that this was the highest
quality brisket known to man you're
Persnickety and it was cut to Perfection
the barbecue sauce Ken was rich
flavorful I gotta tell you this is not a
free ad for Bucky's but it really is
because folks George George walking into
any gas station off of any Interstate
exit is like the doctor walking into
surgery he's got more anti-back on him
than a human should be allowed Wow way
to go Bucky I love some anti-back what's
the lesson there's a whole lot of
opportunity in America today for you to
make the money you want to make you just
gotta go get it speaking of money we
gotta pay some bills we'll be right back
this is the Ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
and Ken Coleman joined by my colleague
George camel thrilled that you are with
us
and um boy it's a big big night I I did
mention this but we're really excited
we've got a Building Wealth live stream
tonight
uh ramseysolutions.com wealth if you
want to join us on that it's going to be
fun live studio audience and uh man it
is it is it is fun times when we have
people in the building George and a lot
of new listeners coming in by the way
all the time I want to say welcome to
you and uh the phone number to jump in
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five Wheeling West
Virginia is where we're gonna go now
Luke is there Luke how can we help
hey how are we doing guys we are having
a blast what's going on with you
oh I'm doing very well too I'm working
on um getting out of debt and basically
I was talking to my dad about that
during Christmas and my Dad tried to
tell me being debt free the pipe dream
will never exist and I said oh why do
you say that he tried to convince me
that electric bills water bills utility
bills car insurance are debts and I
don't believe that to be true
wow man this guy needs a hug is your dad
doing okay
yeah he had a stroke a few years ago but
he's recovered well now on him and I you
know we spend a lot of time together
when I visit and we get along great but
for some reason his perception of money
is not great he lives with my
grandparents his parents and I just
bought my first house this last year so
maybe jealous I don't know well I think
truthfully there's something underneath
that or he's been hurt when it comes to
money and he feels like he's never going
to get ahead and that's where that
attitude comes from I remember I did my
debt free scream on the show and you
know we uploaded to YouTube and all the
comments were just like your dad's why
you're not really debt free you'll
always have bills to pay you'll never be
it's a pipe dream man and so I know that
feeling and I because it's been told to
me before and the truth is your utility
bills are not debt no it's it's just an
expense yeah that's all right it's a
purchase I'm purchasing electricity this
one I am purchasing I'm purchasing water
George this month I mean you have to
think you're not borrowing money because
you're simply purchasing those utilities
does that help you philosophically you
get that
yeah kind of like if I paid cash for a
car it's not dead I had to pay for it
but it's not a dead thing correct that's
correct when you go to the restaurant
and you order a meal you didn't borrow
money you went ahead and ate it then
they brought you the bill and that's how
utilities work you had like the entire
month and now you have to pay for it you
don't have to live off the grid to live
a debt-free lifestyle that doesn't mean
you'll never have any expenses again it
means you'll never have payments to make
for borrowing money with interest again
which makes your life better the whole
goal is to minimize expenses to create
as much margin as possible to create the
life that we want and you are doing that
and so say hey thanks Dad appreciate the
the kind word but uh yeah I'm gonna keep
living my life yeah change the
conversation that's the way to do did
you hear about the black bear that got
loose move on we're gonna change the
conversation it's not an argument or
debate that's really worth having
Indianapolis Indiana is where we go next
Emily is there Emily how can we help
hi um I'm calling to see if I should buy
my dad's fixer-upper
all right tell us more
why do you want to buy it okay
well my landlord is putting my rent up
to 1200 a month I used to pay 800. and
my dad's like well why don't you just
buy my rental property because he
doesn't live in the state anymore and
you could just pay me for that the the
kind of the thing about it is that it
needs to be fixed up because the renters
kind of destroyed it are you debt free
no how much debt do you have
twenty thousand what kind of debt is
that
I have nine thousand on the car and the
rest is my student loan okay
and how much money do you have in
savings
a thousand okay so that would put you at
baby step two in the Ramsay baby steps
and the spot where you would be become a
homeowner buy a house would be baby step
3B where you'd save up that down payment
so the goal right now is to become
completely debt free have a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months
then we can start saving up a down
payment but right now we don't have the
money to to invest into this Fixer-Upper
and buy it from him and it sounds like
it's going to be more of a curse and a
blessing in your life and so I would
just go where else can I rent that's
cheaper or do I need to get a roommate
would that be an option
yeah well he said hey I can rent it to
you for what I'm paying for the mortgage
for it or whatever he said I can rent it
to you and then the money you would be
kind of saving on rent you could just
use it to fix it what would the mortgage
be and what would your rent be then
uh 6.50
okay but then you still need the money
to fix it up
yeah yeah but let's run the math on that
so you're saving 150 if I heard you
write your current rents 800.
yeah but she's putting it up now to
children no no I know but I'm saying if
you take your dad's deal okay and so now
you're paying 650 to your dad you've
saved 150 and his proposal was you take
what you're saving on on rent now going
for 800 a year yeah and so that's not
gonna go very far you can't do a whole
lot of fixing on 150 a month or eighteen
hundred dollars a year and I just want
you to understand that that could get
frustrating pretty quickly what are the
repairs needed
mostly cosmetic like the carpet all
needs on all new carpet paint and
um
like bathroom stuff why isn't he paying
for that
because he just because he's like well
since it's going to be yours and you
need to pay for it
yeah I don't like the spirit of this
discussion if you're going to be a
renter it's not yours
right
right and so I don't want you sinking
money into an asset that you don't even
own yeah you're not going to see any of
the appreciation on that now long term
you may own it one day
yeah but right now you don't and so I
don't want you sinking money into this
thing and all of a sudden he goes hey I
could charge 900 bucks rent you're out
and I'm not going to sell it to you
because I need the money because I'm
retired and don't have enough and so I
need this rental income money and now
this deal you thought was going to
happen doesn't and it creates resentment
and so I I want to protect the
relationship and when you start to mix
the finances with faith with family and
the deal was going to happen and if you
do anything you got to be working with a
real estate attorney get all this
written down with a contract not because
you don't trust them but because it's a
way you say I love you to family
okay and so if he wants to do the
renovations and you pay him 800 bucks
once it's renovated I would take that
deal
but I wouldn't cover these on your own
yeah
okay so here's what here's what here's
what we're trying to help you avoid
to get in a sticky ugly family situation
with your dad
all because your rent's gonna go up 400
bucks a month
what's so really what we're saying is
what is the best solve for that all
right I mean it stinks when your rent
goes up right that's real well what's
the best solution for that and this one
feels like it's got a whole lot of
variables that George has already
pointed out and unless you get clarity
on those variables so now they're no
longer variables it's like this is
what's going on uh don't make a bad
family decision
to save
400 bucks what's your income Emily
um between me and my husband you make 60
a year okay and so your husband's living
there as well
yeah so what's your take-home pay every
month
45
00 okay so if you're looking at about 25
of take-home pay your goal would be to
be paying a thousand dollars a month in
rent and another question is can we get
the income up to where we could afford
the 1200 at around 25 percent of our
take-home pay and still have margin left
over to get out of debt get the
emergency fund start saving it down
payments so that we can be future
homeowners
are you both working full-time
yeah but yeah yeah it feels like you're
hanging on going to school
he's going to school as well so it's
just hard for him to get like a second
job okay are you guys cash flowing that
yeah okay good the goal is to not get
into any more debt and to start paying
the debt we have off to put ourselves in
a better financial position hopefully
going to school will help him increase
that income as well yeah and George I
think you did a really good job of of
helping her see you know what
there's no guarantee that even Dad good
old pop well things can sound good is it
gonna change his mind and create tension
for you because all of a sudden he got
better for him financially oh yeah my
heart rate went up just hearing all that
I didn't like that made me nervous yeah
a little scary good stuff thank you
George always good to be with you my
friend thanks to uh James and the team
in the booth to keep us on the air and
most importantly we want to thank you
America this is your show this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey's
solution broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where America hangs out
to have a real conversation about life
specifically your money your work your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
George camel this hour and we're here
for you to guide you to break through
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five and I do want to say if
you're a new listener and you'd like to
learn more about the baby steps what is
this show what is it really about how
are all the different ways that we can
help you
well we have a great opportunity for you
to get a quick snapshot that'll get you
started on the right path it's the get
started button at our website
ramseysolutions.com ramseysolutions.com
click on get started all right Jake is
up in Tampa Florida Jake how can we help
hey Ken hi George how are you guys doing
today we're having a blast
awesome awesome so uh bear with me I
have a little bit of share I just want
you guys to kind of understand like
where my mind is right now take your
time so I can you guys hear me okay yes
sir loud and clear
awesome so I graduated with my
bachelor's in business management last
May and then this past semester in the
fall
of 2022 I tried grad school out and
pursued an MBA
um and I just found that it wasn't for
me so I dropped out so currently I'm
looking for
a full-time job so right now like as you
know as many high-level people say our
greatest asset is time and I love how
Alex from Moses I know you've talked to
uh Alex Ken is that correct yes
yes I love his perspective on learning
all the skills and eventually deploying
all of them into a business idea or a
great company to work for even
investment opportunities So currently I
don't have any specific passion to
follow or my own business idea to start
so I'm trying to go about my career and
building my skill sets
so I thought starting off would be a
good way to start off would be going
into sales and for the past few months
I've been constantly applying to job
postings reaching out to companies and
employees especially through Linkedin I
seem to can't find uh you know a job
anywhere and no one's wanting to hire me
so I'm not sure if I'm going about it
the wrong way or I'm not really sure
where to start okay so unless you can
help me out with that give me any piece
of advice yeah absolutely
um so let's dig into what you said I'm
having a hard time finding a job and
then you said I can't get people to hire
me so are you getting job interviews
um a few and
um you're making it past the first are
you making it past the first one or are
you just kind of doing the introductory
and you never hear anything
um I actually had two lined up and
they're just basic entry level sales
jobs
um a couple of them were not really any
of interest to me
um but usually I'll have one interview
and then at least the one interview I've
had I went to one interview and then I
didn't hear back from after that all
right well so so let's let's get a
different strategy so right now
you know that sales and you've been
you've been paying attention to Alex and
I think he's right on this and we did a
deep dive interview you can see it at
the Ken Coleman Show YouTube channel the
reason that sales is a good place for
someone who's not quite sure what the
long term looks like while they're
getting cleared I'm going to give you
some resources to actually help you
today all right that's coming in just a
minute
but why sales is absolutely a good path
for UI you're trying to figure things
out is because it's a wonderful
experience you if you can win in sales
you could win in marketing
if you can win in sales you could win in
leadership if you could win in sales you
could win in customer service if you can
win in sales let me tell you something
you can win
because sales at its most fundamental uh
application A salesperson
is problem solving
with a serving Spirit like a great
salesperson is solving a problem through
the the uh
product or service
and they're doing it in a way that is
really service focused you can take that
all the way up the ladder man the CEO
entrepreneur it's a wonderful wonderful
thing so I think what's going on here is
you need to be more urgent and you need
to be less picky so that's my formula
for you I'm going to give you some
tactical things but I think there needs
to be a philosophy for you right now in
my head my in other words your mindset
needs to be I need to be very urgent
and I need to be less picky because I'm
not limited to the first sales job I'm
not limited to the second sales job I
want to get in and start getting some
sales experience and start making money
true or false
true absolutely so
there is a principle that that I created
after George talking I don't know a
couple thousand phone calls uh when we
started the Ken Coleman show years ago
and I came up with it it's called The
Proximity principle and I was trying to
come up with a way for people to
understand how do I get connected to
actually get the job I want and that's
what you're calling about and the
principal says this in order to do what
I want to do sales
I've got to get around people that are
doing it
sales people
sales managers
and I got to get in places where it's
happening I can start getting getting
like maybe I'm online forums maybe I'm
going to conferences on sales like I'm
always thinking about I'm around people
that are successful in sales and I'm
reading about sales I I'm I'm thinking
about companies that have sales
positions are open I'm going who do I
know over there I need to get over there
because here's what happens with the
proximity principle you break it down to
this the right people plus the right
places equals opportunity and so you're
calling me right now and you're saying I
don't have any opportunities and that's
not the case you are in the right places
and you aren't around the right people
because if you're around the right
people in the right places here's what's
going to happen opportunity is going to
come your way you're gonna have
conversations somebody's somebody's
gonna go you're sharp young guy that
wants to sell I'll teach you how to sell
come work for me
now right I want to pause I hit you with
a lot but is what I'm saying is it
hitting you right between the eyes
you're right absolutely so you got to
get busy
what are you doing right now for income
I'm just working part-time jobs right
now on the side I do some marketing for
a couple local
um companies in the area just doing
social media marketing yeah okay if if I
were to pull up uh jobs sales jobs in
Tampa Florida right now what would I see
on tql
um
a lot of insurance jobs you could do
okay so those are the few that popped up
to me or like uh Insight okay so here's
here's the challenge for you Jake you're
working a couple of part-time jobs right
now so the bar is low let's raise the
bar by just going and getting a sales
job go down and get a cart sell a car
tomorrow
go get a job
go start selling something let's start
bringing in more income
than we are and what we're doing is
we're moving forward we're creating some
Forward Motion I'm moving forward and I
actually like George him getting a sales
job that he's not wild about because
it's going to Spur him on and go get
another sales job that he doesn't like
and get some experience too experience
you're not going to be the greatest
salesman day one yeah so here's what I'm
gonna do for you Jake I'm gonna give you
two resources one is the get clear
career assessment it's a 20-minute
assessment
and it's going to give you so much
Clarity on what you do best what you
love to do and results that motivate you
spit out a purpose statement it gives
you a high level job description and
then I want you to read the book from
paycheck to purpose so the assessment is
a compass the book is the guide to climb
the mountain hang on the line we'll get
you that and that's going to give you
tremendous Clarity which will then give
you confidence to actually step out and
move forward thank you young man the
best is yet to be get after it
George Campbell Ken Coleman are here
with you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're gonna stay right here in our
backyard Nashville Tennessee Dwayne is
there Dwayne how can we help yes sir I
have a 200 000 term uh for 20 years it's
got about 19 years left I'm coming up
off another one that's why I got this
other one so overlap it
um but because I'm just coming up off
the first one I'm wondering maybe I
should get a whole life and I'm
listening to what you and I think Susan
everyone say hey whole life is bad but
every time I talk to the mutual mess and
these other they are convincing me no
it's a solid you won't lose money and so
I wanted to call directly and find out
what am I losing when I start talking to
them that it seems like I'm pretty firm
on what I'm listening to what you guys
are saying is there something I'm
missing in Translation well Dwayne
here's a simple way to think about it
what would they stand to gain by
persuading you to get whole life versus
term life from them
I'm sure some kind of financial gain
there we go the commissions on whole
life are astronomical and there's a good
reason your term life policy costs about
five percent of the cost of an
equivalent whole life policy and so when
you're paying you know 15 20 30 bucks a
month for that Term Policy versus 600
well there's a lot more wiggle room for
them to steal your commissions under the
guise of well you're going to build this
cash value policy and you're going to
invest it over a long period of time
you're going to make so much money
Dwayne don't invest in the market invest
with me in this insurance policy do you
see what they're doing there
yeah yeah but it does sound like again
this is what I'm talking to him I get
overwhelmed the numbers and everything
and when they get done they say hey look
see you put this money in which to me is
a huge amount of money per month it is
that you could be investing yourself
into much more uh solid Investments that
have a much better track record
but what they do well here's I'm
guessing here's what they did they did
some real fancy math that was real
complicated to where they're like Dwayne
you just got to trust me man this is
this will work yeah yeah I I have a
little I'm gonna just throw this let's
get out of the money you started the
call by saying that you agreed with us
on whole life you've you've listened to
this and you have an opinion on this
yourself true or false
yes when I listened I said hey that
sounds right because it felt crazy the
money they're asking for right so hold
on so stop don't afford that I know so
stop so remember why you feel that way
we've made a case
and we didn't convince you
you convinced you
and so you walk away going that's nuts
it's crazy to put all that money in
there it doesn't make any sense you got
to remember that do you trust yourself
do you trust your common sense do you
trust that opinion that you came to
before you ever walked in to talk with
these guys typically obviously I do well
I know so no no no but what happens is
you sit down and somebody makes a really
compelling case and they've got this
thing down pat then what they're saying
makes sense too but then you go it
doesn't make sense but now they're
making it sound like it makes sense you
just gotta say I don't think it makes
sense I know it doesn't make sense
here's why I think it's crazy and then
move on
well they're The Fear Factor too that
after 20 years what's going to be the
cost of another term I'm 50.
George can tell you that so the idea is
that now you don't have insurance for
your whole life the idea is that you
follow the Ramsay plan you pay off your
house in 15 years if you do our plan
with a 15-year fixed rate mortgage and
20 years later you've got a huge pile of
money in your investment accounts and
then you become what we call
self-insured where you don't need that
money anymore because you have more than
that in your investment account and you
only need it if someone relies on your
income like a spouse and George real
quick just break that down the money
that you would invest in a whole life
and the return on that versus the money
you would put in the 401K the Stock
Program I mean excuse me mutual fund
program based on the growth of the whole
nine yards that we we you know the
return on that is Big Time different
break it down quickly yeah so if you
take the difference from that whole life
premium with your term premium take the
difference that you would have paid and
you pop that onto our investment
calculator ramseysolutions.com
and let's say you get an average return
even eight to ten percent over 30 years
see what that would turn into Yeah by
doing it on your own you don't need them
because all they're doing is taking most
of that in commissions for the first
bunch of years and eventually maybe
you'll get a crappy return so avoid this
at all costs and run why even talking to
these people go talk to our friends at
Xander they're not going to sell you
this whole life crap and stop even
entertaining these fools yeah it's
absolutely right good advice got me
riled up well I love boy I love it boy
boy loving you I lead a sound life if
that's what gets me riled up Ken but
it's fine well it's fine you're doing it
gives me the juice you're doing great
yeah I like seeing you with the juice
Jay is on the line in our nation's
capital Washington DC Jay how can we
help
hey how are you today we're having a
blast Jay what's up
my question for you is in terms of
paying down my car debt
um I am paying less interest on my car
loan than I'm collecting in the bank I'm
a mutual fund so why would I pull out 25
Grand or so pay it down when I could
just let it accrue the differential
you're a genius Jay so here's an idea
why don't we go borrow as much money as
we can
to funnel into Investments if that's the
case
if it's a locked rate yeah on both sides
would you do it
tell me why I shouldn't have you seen
the stock market Jay am I the only one
Googling around here no I didn't say
that I said to you if you should have
locked rates I have locked rates on my
car loan and my mutual fund what's your
mutual fund making
three nine okay so my money mark my my
high yield savings account makes more
than that and that's guaranteed for how
long
um I have to check that get Squishy
later what if it goes down to three
percent two percent
so then they could pay it off well
here's another question how much is your
car payment
monthly yeah 480. wouldn't it make more
sense to free up 480 dollars to then
funnel into those Investments
and also four percent kind of sucks
you're putting 480 into an index fund or
a mutual fund on average you know over
the next 30 Years with long-term
thinking you could be making eight to
ten percent agreed
and so I'd rather giving that money away
that 20 grand let's say the payoff of my
car
so I could either give it away today or
give it away over the next three years
but one way or another that 20 grand has
to go to the car payments
I just if you went back in time would
you go into debt again for the car
no I don't know why you're defending the
lenders here going well these guys are
my friends because they gave me a low
interest you know I'm trying to figure
what I should do Tim I'm trying I listen
to your payoff about it what's that but
I'm trying to figure out why I should
give away my 20 grand I can't convince
you that a debt-free lifestyle is going
to give you a better life you're not
giving away with you you're not I agree
with you no but you got the wrong
narrative you've really concocted this
in your head and if you're here to
debate us we're not going to I know
you're not no I'm not but listen brother
I'm just but but it keeps coming back to
that and I think you've got the wrong
narrative The Narrative is why should I
give away twenty thousand the real
question you should ask yourself is why
did I borrow twenty thousand dollars for
a car that I couldn't afford you put
yourself in the 20 I know your narrative
is it is wise to leverage debt in order
for me to build wealth and I have found
that debt is not a friend of mine it
doesn't help me build wealth it steals
from my paycheck it steals from my joy
it robs me of so much and so therefore
here's the way to think about it what if
every dollar coming into my house I
could use for whatever I wanted and I
could invest that money and get more
than a four percent return long term
what if I could have paid cash for a car
that allowed me to do that so what's
your income
uh 180. you're making 180 000 dude
for a car
why'd you do that in the first place
making that incredible of an income
I hear you I hear you I'm wondering dude
you're crushing it and you could really
build some amazing wealth are you a net
worth millionaire yet
no my question is why the heck not you
make a hundred and eighty thousand
dollars yeah and we're wondering what
we're doing with we're trying to play
games I'll tell you what because he's
spending 480 a month as one example
towards a depreciating asset not sound
financial decision making now we're not
knocking on you we're trying to help you
see what the real narrative ought to be
in your mind why am I spending 480 a
month for a car
Jay try this pay off the car you could
probably do it today I imagine you have
the money and live a debt free life for
a year and if you hate it if you
absolutely hate where you are you can
always go get a loan they'll be happy to
give it to you at home credit card three
percent interest rate oh they love you
you could always go get more debt I like
that one George that was a fun one we
had some fun there hopefully Jay you
didn't take it uh too personal oh we're
fine for everybody we're for you this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
we're thrilled that you are here this is
where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life so
specifically your money your work and
your relationships all of those are tied
together if you want to live a life well
I'm Ken Coleman joined by George
Campbell the phone number if you want to
jump in is triple eight eight two five
two two five eight eight two five five
two two five uh if you're going well who
are you uh hi how you doing my name is
Ken I'm one of the Ramsay personalities
and I focus on work specifically I want
you doing work that you are good at that
you love and that matters to you that is
purposeful work and let me tell you what
happens you have a greater income and
greater impact all right that's what I
do as a part of Ramsey Solutions and I
host the Ken Coleman show we covered a
story earlier today and James the
producer said this is this is
interesting
and uh so this comes out of the news but
George it's not just a news story
it's actually a pervasive problem
and uh the story in the news right now
in fact it's one of the hottest stories
right now comes from the political world
this guy uh named George Santos have you
heard of this guy oh yeah so he's like
George is out there you don't keep all
the Georges well so he's a newly elected
congressman from New York if you don't
know what I'm talking about and uh he's
taken a lot of heat from the media
rightfully so because it's come out and
almost it feels like every day the dude
has just lied and lied and lied and lied
to cover up those lies about his resume
his backgrounds he just lied to
everybody
and boy you know pressure on this guy to
resign and it's a little bit ironic that
people are now shocked at a politician
lied that's the first time in history a
politician has lied yeah so this is big
news so everybody's trying to grasp that
deal
um and and and and then but you know
what there's a deeper thing here and
there's a Temptation for all of us to do
what George Santos has done I'm going to
break that down in a second but I wanted
George you pulled up give us a if you
would just a couple of the Fantastical
lies that this uh this Congressman has
laid out for everybody lied about where
he went to school lied about where he
worked lied about owning a number of
rental properties lied about being
robbed of his rent money lied about his
criminal status in Brazil lied to donors
lied about his athletic accomplishments
lied about the timing of his mother's
death lied about his campaign finances
and this one might be them the funniest
one he lied about being Jewish and then
he came back and said no no no I said I
was Jewish which is which is even worse
than the LIE it has borderline comedic
yeah wow oh my gosh yeah I mean so this
is a guy this is pathological though
that's the one right no these are
pathological liar now why don't we bring
this up
in the work context for a moment for
those of you who feel a sense of doubt
maybe you are dealing with imposter
syndrome and we took a call from a young
man early this hour trying to get a job
and when we face doubt George
it it tempts us to be deceitful
because we feel like if I'm not good
enough
uh I I've gotta make up a story that
makes me good enough
that's the slippery slope and that's
what he did well he took fake it until
you make it to a very dangerous level
here man I mean it's just believable so
doubt leads to deceit when we don't
manage our doubt I don't think I'm good
enough I don't think I'll get the job I
don't think they'll like me I don't
think she'll marry me I mean this thing
spirals out of control and it's all
deceit lying like this and and this is
unbelievable folks listen to this data
this is this is right here in my hands
CNBC article 55
of Americans admit to lying on their
resume at least once
55 George this is according to a recent
survey from standout CV and now it gets
worse by the way before I tell you this
data if anybody out there wants to
really know
what we the people are really like you
want to know what the people of the
world are really like you want to know
the true Human Condition go look at
Google searches
that's the ultimate indicator of who we
are as humans
case in point
the number of Google searches about how
to fake a resume
is up the search is for how to fake a
resume is up 48 George
uh so what are people lying about here
real quick the top eight reasons or what
they are lying about on their resume
55 of people lie about their previous
work experience well that's smart
because we know no one's going to check
your references
I got anxiety thinking about this George
how do you keep up with the audacity
that you could even pull this off is
impressive here's another one this is my
personal favorite because of the
humility excuse me uh the opportunity to
humiliate yourself 43 people uh admit to
lying about their skills
oh yeah I can operate heavy machinery or
even worse we'll see you on Monday
morning Ken you've done this one I know
Excel
it's a dangerous one yeah but no heavy
machinery what are you doing man that
one could be life literally a
life-altering uh 41 lie about their
college degree 39 lie about personal
details such as age location or name
uh 39 lie about high school hey can I
set everybody free who's tempted to lie
about high school nobody cares what you
did in high school no one not even your
mom or dad because they've forgotten
uh 33 lie about salary
33 lie about Job specific software or
equipment skills and then finally 21 and
this is so moronic I don't even know how
to process it
21 of people lie on their resume about
their employer references
so I guess they're making that up hey
George will you do me a solid I'm
putting you down as a reference oh so I
give him Ken's number and I go yeah he
was my previous manager give him a call
he'd be happy to talk to you and I slip
you a 20 Bill and say hey Ken if they
call make me look good yeah I I feel
like I need a shower that's how dirty I
feel right now so the solution here Ken
obviously is to have integrity which if
I'm hiring someone I want to hire
someone with Integrity how do we get
over this hump yeah so back to the the
reason I always like to try to give you
a deep Source behind why we do what we
do and I think doubt is what leads us to
deceit so then if we we need to manage
doubt better what do we do
so if a doubt the way I Define doubt
George is that I don't believe that
Something Good Can Happen um
that's doubt I just don't believe that
something good this thing that I long
for this thing that I want to do it
can't happen I doubt that it can happen
for a variety of reasons and so what you
have to do there is you got to go number
one I can't shortcut this doubt I I
can't take my doubt in myself and then
try to shortcut it by lying to everybody
else no I've got to step into me and go
what is the voice of Doubt telling me
I'm too old is that true
I'm a stay-at-home mom I've got nothing
to offer if I enter the workforce is
that true is there any evidence that
that the doubt is telling you the truth
because if doubt is telling you the
truth it's protecting you give you a
silly example
George if there's a basketball a 10-foot
basketball goal in the lobby
and I tell all these fine people
watching hey I can dunk have you ever
seen me dunk before watch this I'm gonna
dunk and moments before I go to dunk the
ball I have some serious doubt because I
haven't stretched and let's be honest
I've never dunked a basketball and
Doubt's going I don't know if you can do
this Doubt's protecting me from certain
humiliation silly example but you get
the point I'd lower the hoop for you Ken
just for the record thank you but even
then it'd be a question mark all right
but if doubt is saying I can't ever
start a business I can't pay off debt I
can't get through the baby steps I can't
earn enough money to
that's holding you back that's the idea
so instead of lying trying to shortcut
which is what people do here to get the
job you got to go what am I doubting why
am I doubting is there any evidence to
support that and then when we get clear
that hey I actually can do this if I go
get qualified if I go make some
connections now all of a sudden we're
not having to lie and here's the big
takeaway the reason we bring this up is
because you can do severe damage to your
ability to earn money
if you get caught lying like this yeah I
mean it because if you're lying on a
resume you'll lie on the job
and and that's the idea and if I'm the
hiring manager I'd rather you come to me
and say Hey listen I know you require
this much experience here's what I'm
bringing to the table I know I'm not
quite there but here's what I'm doing to
get there I'm impressed you're ready to
hire this guy right versus someone lying
to my face yeah yeah not good come on be
better George Santos I'm trying to
represent George's out here you know
Foreman Lopez Costanza Washington I like
that put respect on our name you know
what the problem is the guy he's holding
on for dear life he's lied so much he
doesn't even know how to unravel or
admit any of them I don't even know if
his name's George anymore why we should
look into that but I know your name is
George I know my name is Ken and I know
that this is the Ramsey Show not a lie
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
George camel with a K by the way thank
you for that Ken get that right triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five uh it's time to talk about the big
night again George you got plans tonight
I'm getting jazzed because I'm gonna be
on stage tonight Ken big keynote don't
miss it yep big oh yeah are you is it a
keynote you doing they call it in Show
Business how long are you gonna speak
for about 20 minutes 20 minutes right
here live leave a lot more huh leave
them wanting more yeah I know that I'll
be wanting more I know that uh so
tonight in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
where we're broadcasting right now
Building Wealth live stream
um this has been a very popular event we
had a very full and very fantastic dare
I say uh fall tour yes uh sold out
crowds everywhere and tonight uh it is
here in the building
it's a free live stream for you it's
happening tonight at 7 pm Central 8
Eastern
Dave Ramsey on the stage Rachel Cruz
George Campbell on stage speaking
keynoting as George likes to say
and my colleague Dr John deloney and I
are joining for a uh well what we like
to call a round table I'm going to say a
spirited discussion a spirited
discussion and uh so you know I'm not
going home after work I'm uh you know
hanging around tonight at the office
it's gonna love it gonna be a lot of fun
and you can still get in and did I
mention that it's free I think I did
ramseysolutions.com wealth
ramseysolutions.com wealth
ramseysolutions.com wealth to sign up
it's going to be a lot of fun and what
are we going to be talking about George
I'll tell you I got The Insider
knowledge yeah you do so
Dave is going to kick it off giving us
some hope in some some dark times and
giving us some perspective
um with some great storytelling some
great inspiration some great tactical
things we can do and then I get up there
and I show you how to create margin to
build wealth and the true reason most
people aren't Building Wealth they don't
have the margin to do it and so I've got
some real tactical steps to walk you
through Rachel then comes up giving us
some you know quench quilting our fears
about the real estate the stock market
what's happening the ups and the Downs
how to ride the roller coaster to why
you should get on the ride and stay on
it for the long term and then we're
going to have a great discussion with
all five of us you and Dr John deloney
talking about what we're looking at for
2023 as far as the trends go oh you know
I like talking about the trends you're
very trendy very trendy uh no I'm not at
all uh and does your margin keynote does
it involve anything on uh uh brisket at
Bucky's you know I didn't work that into
the talk but it may not be too late
I feel like we could probably get a
slide together pretty quickly the night
is still young because I do reference uh
the Costco hot dog so there's one reason
to tune are you a proponent of the
Costco hot dog huge proponent how does
that fit into your very Persnickety uh
clean eating well it's called a tea skin
yes with baited breath if that's a
gluten-free vegan hot dog at Costco it's
gonna blow my mind man I'm not touching
that thing with a 10-foot pole okay
Costco is better than that they know me
better can I just for everybody who
follows you on Instagram at George
Campbell by the way you're saying thank
you at Ken Coleman and while you're
following just jump on over and say hi
to me uh I'd like to see you go to
Costco and do an Instagram reel on on
that can I be honest I went to Costco
and I had my Kirkland Signature
sweatshirt on and I almost wore the
matching sweatpants that I have don't
ever say that in public again I know
well my wife dissuaded me from wearing
these top to bottom Kirkland Signature
she's a good woman but that's how big of
a Kirkland Signature fan I am I went to
Sam's Club the other day I felt like I
was cheating on them
I was okay I can't be found out can you
imagine man I didn't even know Kirkland
had a signature line of clothing and I
now wish that uh I didn't know I might
get you the sweatshirt for you I'm not
gonna wear it good to know never gonna
wear it duly now triple eight eight two
five five two two five Mike is on the
line in Raleigh North Carolina Mike how
can we help
hey guys how are you today well we're
having a little too much fun what's
going on
I'm having fun too so I'm just gonna get
right into it
um my question is
um how do we save for a baby because my
wife is pregnant and she's due in July
with our first child hey hey hey
congratulations that is awesome thank
you is uh do we know do we know if it's
a little boy or little girl
we are finding that out on Saturday
actually uh-oh you're doing one of those
big gender reveal parties yeah
no we're gonna get a very small cake and
it's gonna be a very intimate thing
between my wife and I we're just gonna
cut it open and see what happens that's
love it that's really cool well as far
as expenses go are you feeling like this
is going to be a big Financial way do
you guys have good health insurance in
place
yeah we should I just went full time
with uh uh
um an I.T service providing company so
I'm waiting to see what the health
insurance is going to be there
um you know no debt whatsoever except
for the mortgage you know three to six
months emergency funds you know we we've
done all the baby steps so we're
I I just my biggest concern is not going
back into debt
um once our son or daughter is born I
love that very normal first of all I'd
continue saving to give you some peace
because there's going to be some cost
probably out of pocket uh for the baby
and we want to make sure that you know
mama and baby come home healthy and so
we call that stork mode and that's kind
of when you're pausing the baby steps to
stack up as much cash as possible until
baby and mama are home and healthy and
some of the costs you can expect are of
course the you know the checkups the
prenatal care it's going to be a huge
cost diapers the ultrasounds the lab
work the prenatal vitamins the dietary
needs the maternity clothes the baby
gear all right so you know what this is
good because the big ticket items is
where you would worry right your health
care and you're doing it but you know
what you need to do honestly and lean on
some lean on some friends that have
little ones in your in your world you
guys are doing life with or even your
mother or her mom and just like
literally go go to Target go to go to
George when people go to get diapers for
you you're Mr Walmart I'm a Target guy
Target Walmart here's the deal just go
price out diapers take your wife with
you by the way okay
I went shopping for diapers and I was
like get those those are the cheapest
ones she looked at me like I had grown
horns in my head We're not gonna put
those on our kid it's like why we're the
only ones looking at it and they're
crapping in them anyway what's the
problem
like I would get the Kirkland diaper I
wouldn't get the most expensive I'm
going I'm going to Costco or Sam's Club
and we have a little bit of fun but
literally go price out a box of diapers
get an idea how many diapers are going
to go through in a month start looking
at the little baby food once they get to
the point where they're doing the little
jars and the little spoons and all that
price it out like literally treat it
like you would your grocery budget so
that you get an idea beyond the medical
and all the bigger stuff just get an
idea I think you're gonna find wait a
second
they are expensive little things but I
can do this and talk to your friends
that have babies because they'll tell
you oh we got 17 000 things and we only
use seven that's and so here's the
things you really need to buy here's the
things that are worth getting quality
you know the car seat I'll tell you
one thing my friend
uh this isn't financial advice this is
just life advice invest in a baby wipe
warmer oh there we go or put that in the
old registry you'll never regret having
one of those that's impressive okay Mike
I've got a stat here for you that could
might help you get some numbers around
this uh Healthcare cost Institute says
that the average regular delivery with
an in-network insurance provider and out
of pocket cost is going to come out to
about 13 14 Grand now it can vary it can
go from you know Seven Grand On The Low
End 18 on the high end so I don't know
what it might be in North Carolina but
start to actually price that out
you know right now we we just got a bill
um in the mail that's saying like uh
every month we have to pay 300 towards
um the delivery and I think the final
price that was on there was like 4 800 5
000 something along those lines but
we're we're stocking money away like
yeah we're back in baby step two again
which means you're fine that's 3C yeah
3C yeah wow Mike for uh nominee for
caller of the year it's amazing early
with the baby step 3C there oh very good
the truth is once the baby's here the
baby's gonna become a line item in the
budget for those expenses like formula
and food and child care and books and
toys and uh you know clothing you might
have higher Water and Electric bills of
course the diapers uh so that's kind of
the big the big things to worry about as
far as the budget goes but you guys have
put yourselves in a financial spot that
most people are dreaming about being in
which is no debt and a bunch of money in
the bank so it's something you can
breathe easy on the financial side and
instead get excited about this new baby
being born Mike you're gonna be a dad
and you're gonna be a great dad and you
guys are okay man stay off the internet
and all the fear articles don't go to
WebMD yeah just save yeah don't do that
man let me tell you something to stay
off those websites where they tell you
here's how much a kid cost to raise in
2023 million dollars yeah stay off of
that stuff you're good George Campbell
always fun to be with you sir good hour
I want to thank James and the team and
you America for listening this is your
show this is the Ramsey Show
you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
this is the random show it's where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life specifically your money
your work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman joined in studio this hour by my
colleague George Campbell we're Ramsey
personalities and we're here to guide
you through this hour the phone number
is
888-825-5225 that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five and this is a
special treat we have a special guest in
studio uh and we pulled him away from
preparation for tonight we've been
telling you throughout the show that
tonight's a very big Night Live from the
lobby of Ramsay Solutions HQ is the
Building Wealth live stream event and
Dave will be leading us out and he's
joining us in studio been prepping for
the talk welcome sir well it's good to
be here it's a little weird sitting in
this seat is as weird as it is for you
it's weirder for me it's like everybody
first time I was in the car and I let my
son drive and he was 14 and I was over
in the passenger seat I'm hitting the
brake Dave's got no break yeah no break
over there yeah but it doesn't but I
mean that's kind of how it feels he
can't stop me but he can't fire me and
uh so he can't stop you temporarily I
can stop you permanently you can't
that's it yeah yeah he could absolutely
put a stop to it and make no mistake but
we're excited uh you know we're really
fired up uh if you're just joining us
this hour uh this event is going to be
unbelievable the theme is Building
Wealth and it's a new year uh the
economy seems to be reported on
differently every week but the reality
is is that sound financial principles
are still true and they still work and
while we've been teaching for decades
still works and but a lot of you are
scared you're uncertain and we want to
address that you can still build wealth
starting tonight Building Wealth in 2023
could start tonight it is our live
stream event 7 P.M Central 8 Eastern
Rachel Cruz news we'll be doing a
keynote George Campbell will be
keynoting Dave Ramsey keynoting and then
Dr John deloney and I will be joining
for a fun conversation and the whole
point of it is is to help you look at
today's current state of the finance and
economic world and what it means to you
and your ability to control your future
fears about the economy job loss
recession and then how to create margin
beat inflation build wealth and worry
less about money and again it's free so
I don't know what big plans you've got
going on tonight but you're not going to
get more Roi than this
join us by going to ramseysolutions.com
wealth at ramsaysolutions.com wealth you
can register right now yeah right and
they'll send you a link to be able to
watch the thing for free this is an
event that if we were on the road in
your city you would pay a lot of money
to come to and it's completely free and
I just left a marketing meeting before I
came in here with the team working on
this for the last several weeks and they
are thrilled uh we're well over 200 000
folks are going to be viewing whoa and
uh we're really really excited about
that uh TBN is also going to be
broadcasting it and so uh it's gonna be
a great night it's going to be a lot of
fun and you're going to learn a lot and
there is this weird thing happening in
the one hand all of our data tells us
when we're talking to you on the air and
anecdotally and also in actual research
we're hearing how many people are
distressed how many people are afraid
how much anxiety there is how much fear
there is
and yet you can't get a freaking parking
spot at the mall
I don't understand yeah you can't find a
new car on the lot they're all sold I
don't understand the real estate market
is horrible
but you can't find a house for sale
it's the weirdest thing I mean everybody
is distressed and I think the way
they're medicating it is they're
spending like they're in Congress that's
exactly right I don't know man it's
crazy out there you hear what on the one
hand how depressed people are and how
sad it is and how long your face is and
all that and yet you can't stay out of
the mall and quit pushing Prime on your
magic wand in your pocket prime prime
and crap sleep showing up at your dad
gum front door magically yeah like like
dadgum Santa Claus brought it or not
that was last month people uh so we're
gonna have a fun tonight we're going to
talk about real stuff real people like
adult stuff and um
and we're not going to talk about
children we're going to talk about
adults and so yeah it is a time to be I
understand when there's when the
leadership in the nation
uh can't string a sentence together that
it scares you I understand that the
Island of Misfit Toys can't find their
butt with both hands in Washington and
that scares you understand that the FED
apparently married their cousin I mean I
don't know this is the dumbest time I've
ever seen and so I understand when you
look at that how it's gloomy but you can
control some things in your life that
control you control the controllables
and in spite of that oh and by the way
inept government is not new
it wasn't new 20 years ago it wasn't new
30 years ago when I went on the air
and so you know you can't sit around
blaming up the economy the economy is in
your dead gum brain
you've got to decide what you're going
to do and we're going to walk you
through that tonight we understand I've
been scared I've been terrified I put
myself in positions where I didn't know
how we were going to keep the lights on
as a matter of fact we didn't keep the
lights on they came and pulled them they
turned the dadgum water off and Rachel
was a brand new baby and I was so scared
I couldn't breathe I understand what
stupid looks like in the in the hell it
brings into your life I understand that
and yet I we're also it's not okay we're
not going to live there we're not going
to live in this sense of angst this
sense of ambivalence and so this is all
about hope tonight yeah and very
practical and George you know we've been
talking about this in our fall tour of
Building Wealth and and so now we're
bringing it here and we're taking it
live stream but you know one of the
things we've realized when we when we
talked to debt free screamers who stand
on that stage right across the lobby is
inflation's not freaking them out now
why well I think in spite of what's
happening out there they've decided oh I
can control the guy in the mirror and I
can start getting on a budget and I can
get out of debt to put myself in a
better financial position and I can have
an emergency fund so I don't have to
turn to the credit card company
companies to do it for me and what that
does is it puts you in a position to
build wealth because now you have your
income at your disposal to invest and
you're not freaking out because you're
prepared for those emergencies and so
that's the hope I want people to leave
with tonight I remember when I was broke
and I was talking to one of my buddies
who was a lot older than me he had more
gray hair than I did at the time and I
said you know that car costs twenty two
thousand dollars to get a new car back
then you know a long time ago
twenty two thousand dollars who can
afford that he goes you can't
yeah right you can't well there's that
yeah that's true you can't so that's
adult talk right there that's like you
you can't buy everything well Dad come
bless your little heart welcome to life
no is a possible answer to some of your
questions yeah and so you know that with
that boundary and with that
understanding with that emotional
maturity you can be set free from
hopelessness from anxiety and from a
sense of being overwhelmed you get
overwhelmed when you're reaching for
things you know I would be overwhelmed
if I was trying out for the NBA yeah the
way I'd like to see that yeah I know you
wouldn't no you would be brilliant you
see Dave in the sweatpants
I I think he'd beat us trampoline would
we need I don't I need a trampoline to
get on the trampoline right yeah there
is that you know we've been talking
about margin though you know margin
really means it's freedom and you're
gonna be talking about that too George
yeah just real freedom and you don't
have to worry about what a politician is
doing so Dave thanks for stopping by and
then we've got more stuff caffeinated
the guy is fired up let's get this done
tonight be joining up wow hey we're not
fooling around with this we're gonna
punch this in the nose let's get it
people let's get it seven o'clock
tonight ramseysolutions.com wealth did
we mention it's free shut up about
inflation it's free
folks he may break through a wall like
Kool-Aid used to do in the commercials
when I was a kid he's fired up you don't
want to miss it ramseysolutions.com
wealth to sign up for free now hey don't
move more Ramsey's show right around the
corner
[Music]
[Music]
the Ramsay show continues continuing to
give you hope through practical steps
forward clear path forward to win in
your money in your work in your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
George camel the phone number to jump in
on the conversation with your question
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five it's time now for
a fun thing that we like to do we take
your questions called question of the
day and it's brought to you by hummus
that's right a smooth creamy tantalizing
mixture of chickpeas tahini olive oil
garlic lemon juice what's there not to
love about hummus Ken delicious and
nutritious hummus question of the day
today's question comes from Bethany in
Indiana I'm currently working for a
company I've been at for 10 years and
I'm at the highest position I can hold
within the company I haven't had a raise
in six years aside from 3 three percent
cost of living each year and when I
recently asked for a raise I was given a
five percent raise I'm also about to go
on my third unpaid maternity leave I'm
disappointed because I thought I was
more valuable to the company and that
they would care about how inflation is
hurting all of us is it worth staying at
this company or should I look elsewhere
if I leave what is the best thing I
should do with the 28 000 in my 401k the
job I'm considering taking will not
allow me to roll over my contributions
the job I'm considering would pay the
same but it'll allow me to be home with
my children for most of the day and have
a very flexible schedule okay so George
this is about equal parts Coleman camel
here love it uh I'll just say this
um I'm gonna cut right to the chase in
the question about the raise and how she
feels devalued
um first of all
um
I don't think it's right that you didn't
have some type of conversation about
just a general you know kind of what is
a standard uh increase based on
performance over six years something's
missing there we can't dive into that
because I don't know why you went six
years however you recently asked for a
raise and you were given a five percent
raise
um and then the thing is I thought I was
more valuable to the company they would
care about how inflation is hurting all
of us now here's the deal if the theory
is is that as inflation Rises my income
must rise
that is flawed and that is not
sustainable when the economy and all the
mitigating factors that go into what
creates inflation
make the cost of goods and services go
up
your employer is not responsible for
that so therefore they are not
responsible to try to keep Pace with
that
that's just not realistic and it's an
unfair expectation so I'm just going to
address that because I think a lot of
people feel that we see that sometimes
in the news and headline it kind of has
a socialistic flair to it but it just
doesn't work that way because I'll
remind you that when companies pay
people more and right now we're at an
unbelievable uh wage growth period right
now in the United States hourly wages
are up salaries up that's why over 75
million people change jobs in the last
year and a half they're going for a
bigger paycheck guess what happens
simply
companies will then pass on their
increased cost to you that's why your
combo meal at Mickey D's George is a lot
more expensive and they cut the toy okay
brutal so insult to injury there it is
so enough on the inflation thing here's
the deal you should probably take the
job that you're being offered because of
the flexibility and the pay is still the
same now she's got a very interesting
401K question yes so what to do with the
401K you said the job you're considering
taking will not allow you to roll over
the contributions that's totally fine
because I want you to do a direct
rollover to an IRA outside of your
employer so you're saying hey they won't
let me roll it over to the new 401K
that's totally fine because when you do
a direct rollover to to the IRA you've
got more investing options you're in in
control and that's a great thing and so
I wouldn't worry about that it sounds
like this is an awesome role to step
into and I hope they treat you better
than the current employer yeah it's that
simple thank you so much for the
question again question today brought to
you by hummus hummus nutritious and
Cameron is on the line here in Franklin
Tennessee right where we are Cameron how
can we help
hey guys um yeah my wife and I got into
some really serious credit card debt and
we were trying to find some options
because the essentially payments have
just gotten too high for us to really
keep up with with all the rest of our
expenses and everything and so we had um
been contacted by
um a group that would that could do some
debt consolidation for us essentially on
our behalf um cut our credit card debt
by a significant amount and then pay
this group over a series of about 48
months um they fixed a monthly payment
which is much less than what our minimum
payments on our credit cards would be so
I'm just curious because I've never
dealt with groups like this I'm not too
familiar with them is this a good idea
to
um go into a good option or is there
other options that would be a better use
to you know take care of this
um this problem that we have here
well the credit consolidation here is
not a silver bullet and you can't borrow
your way out of debt and so I know
temporarily it feels like well if we can
get this interest under control we get
the payment under control then we will
be able to solve this the problem is we
didn't actually hit the underlying
symptom which is we've been spending out
our eyeballs and so I would uh continue
to make payments on your current credit
cards listed out from smallest to
largest what does that add up to in your
monthly payments
yeah our monthly payments which is about
1200 a month okay what's the total
amount of credit card debt
of 42 000.
and what are the interest rates on those
cards what's the range
uh it ranges anywhere between about 15
to 22 and what is your household income
um 115 Grand a year good and what other
debt do you have outside of the credit
cards
um we have our mortgage and then we also
have a couple car loans but one of the
car loans we're just about to pay off
here in a couple months so that'll be
wiped
um and that's really it good what's that
payment on that car loan that's about to
be paid off
oh it's about 3 30 a month all right so
that will give you an extra 330 in your
budget to throw at the credit cards
what's the other car worth and what do
you owe on it
you have a car I'm not sure what it's
worth um I bought it for 15 grand
um and there's about I want to say
99
000 left to pay off on it okay you can
also look into that as an option if you
can sell that thing you know you owe
nine and you can sell it for 15 and we
downgrade and car and get get something
cheaper for now that's also an option to
help speed up this debt payoff process
but the real key is taking control of
that 115 000 and you're saying you can't
afford the 1200 payment so what else is
happening in your expenses that's
causing you to not be able to afford
that
yeah I mean it's just it's our you know
our mortgage and you know just um what's
your mortgage payment
it's uh 27.50 a month
all right what's your take-home pay
um take-home pay is uh about 7 800 a
month
all right so that mortgage has taken up
a big chunk at 35 percent of your
take-home pay which is also hurting you
but this is definitely doable because
that means you've got you know the other
65 percent obviously you've got some
bills to pay uh are either of you able
to work overtime
um no not really my wife
um she she she works um as part of a
Prayer Ministry and
um receives donations through that but
that's kind of really those those uh
those amounts and kind of what we get
from that really fluctuates and
everything
um so it's in terms of like a
fixed income it's it's uh it's mine that
we have right now okay well here's what
I want you to do I'm gonna gift you one
year of every dollar premium so that you
guys can get on a plan list out your
income your expenses track everything
and what you're going to do is a budget
audit you're going to go through every
single expense and go can we do better
do we need this right now what can we
cut you're gonna go find some money in
your budget because it's there and
you're going to pay off these credit
cards and all it takes is a little bit
of progress to now make this manageable
instead of paying these credit card
consolidation companies who are just out
there to screw you and so we call it Con
consolidation for a reason emphasis on
the con
um and so I would not go through this
consolidation process
um what's the interest rate going to be
did you look at that with them what the
payment would be
yeah I have it here in front of me
um essentially
what what their totals be because
they're saying that they can get the my
debt cut down to 22 Grand and then they
add on 10 grand to their fee I don't
trust them with a 10-foot pole man I'm
running away from these guys they're
making a lot of empty promises and
you're going to start paying them
monthly fees to fix this thing and it's
not going to be fixed you're the
solution Cameron and I totally believe
you can do this list out your debts use
our debt snowball calculator to show you
what this plan looks like smallest to
largest regardless of the interest rate
you will be debt free soon my friend you
just got to get on a plan Cameron you
got to believe and we're here to walk it
through with you you've got this he's
George Campbell I'm Kidd Coleman this is
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Coleman joined by George Campbell with
Ramsay personalities and you joined the
Ramsey show where America hangs out they
get common sense
clear steps to move forward in your
money life your work life and your
relationship life triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
jump in triple eight eight two five five
two two five the City of Angels Los
Angeles is where we go next Keith is
there Keith howker wheel
hi
um I guess my main question is I just
graduated from school about
less than a month ago
um and I guess I'm trying to find a job
because I moved back home
and I'm just guess I'm asking should I
be focusing solely to look for a
career-based job or should I just find a
job in the interim just so I can be
making money okay so do you have an idea
what ladder you want to be on what
career path what 20 years 30 years might
look like you got some ideas
yeah I want to do something with data
analytics or business intelligence or
business analytics
um because my degree is
um business administration with a focus
and information systems so
I would not take any old job now
if you need to get a couple part-time
jobs
uh or a full-time short-term job and
what I mean by that is you know if
you're out delivering ubereats or
something and you can make enough money
but I don't want you just taking any job
the reason is is because you can get in
somewhere
with this desire where you want to end
up and with the degree you have and just
the skill set entry level there are
entry-level jobs that I would rather you
go after because it gets you in the door
the proximity principle is a book that I
wrote I'm going to give it to you as my
gift okay it's a best-selling book and
it I can sum the proximity principle up
very simply it says in order to do what
I want to do I've got to be around
people that are doing it and in places
where it is happening your mindset right
now is I got to get around people that
are doing this kind of work or running
companies that do this kind of work or
have opportunities and I'm just willing
to get in so instead of just any job
we're going to get a strategic
entry-level job so that I am in close
proximity
to the people that are doing what I want
to do or to the work that I want to do
and I know if I do a good job I'm going
to get an opportunity to get on that
ladder does that make sense the way I'm
laying that out to you
yeah like let's let's be strategic
because if I am using the proximity
principle and getting in that uh getting
in a job or an area a company a sector
where I'm going to have opportunity to
move up
then essentially I'm getting paid to be
prepared
that's how I want you to think of it as
opposed to if I go get just any job that
pays me what I need but I'm not
strategically located to be able to get
in and move up George I know that you've
done this well in fact yeah and George I
mean George lived this out I mean before
I wrote that book I I could have said
you are a case study and and you've
lived this well it takes a level of a
little of that hustle and grind where
you kind of you show up and you go hey I
love data analytics I love what your
company is doing and I want to get in
the door are there any roles even if
it's a temp job or an internship where I
could step in because I just love what
you guys are doing I want to be a part
of it and you start to get a foot in the
door you may not get the job that you
wanted right out of college but man if
you do that and you have competency and
skill you're gonna rise up very very
quickly and show how valuable you are so
do you know any companies that you want
to work for currently
I mean I know my goal
um obviously coming out of school was
trying to I mean obviously it's not
going to happen you know right away but
um I mean I know my goal is working for
one of the bigger companies but that
won't I don't think that will happen
until I get the experience yeah start to
look at those resumes
what is needed you say hey all right
they're looking for three years of
experience this kind of credentials this
Google analytics course and all of a
sudden you have a path to get there yeah
you know let's do a little bit of fun
Keith let's let's pretend that George
and I want to do what you want to do but
we don't know as much as you do and and
we say to you Keith what skills do I
need to get in an entry-level job so
that I can get where you're going what
would you say to us
well I know a big thing for data
analytics
um and that most companies are looking
for is that you have a good foundation
of knowing database software such as SQL
as well as knowing you know spreadsheets
spreadsheet software like Microsoft
Office Excel or Google Sheets
um Etc as well as another database
software that Microsoft uses Microsoft
Access which not a lot of people use but
some companies are looking for people
that know that software so do you see
what just happened
no no you became the teacher for us in
an exercise so you know what you need to
get you know what you need to do so this
is this is the stage that you're in what
do I need to be learning
what do I need to be doing
what do I need to be learning what I
mean what do I need to be doing and
that's the entry level job we're looking
for said I'm getting paid to learn
getting paid to do and you're going to
be fine young man so hang on the line
let's give Keith a copy of the proximity
principle and while we're at it while
I'm giving stuff away give him a copy of
from paycheck to purpose uh the
proximate principal George is a deep
dive into the get connected stage which
is one of the seven stages the clear
path to doing what you were born to do
which is in from paycheck to purpose but
you know you and I uh we both did this
along with by the way lived it out you
know this you knew me when I was doing
what I write about in both of those
books that's right I've known you before
you were even at Ramsey yeah where I was
around that's right but what the things
that you and I did we were very very
intentional
and diligent and what I mean by that is
we knew who we needed to get around who
we needed to talk to who's going to be a
decision maker and and we just kept at
it and when you do that with persistence
and but not being weird about it you
know don't be a stalker that's not what
we're saying but going on LinkedIn for
example Keith and just starting to
search data analytics who can I connect
with who's even in these roles who do
they know and it has a ripple effect and
all of a sudden you're active you're
commenting on things you're posting you
got to be out there proactively a lot of
people are waiting Ken for something to
just like fall on their lap waiting for
someone to email me because I put my my
resume on one of these giant sites it
doesn't always work like that it doesn't
and I think you can confirm this and
this is this is a little nugget here
that I hope free some people's minds
right now when I'm around the right
people and in the right places I don't
actually have to ask for opportunity I
have found that opportunity comes to me
like if you're actually in the right
place the right time happens have you
seen that in your absolutely yeah I mean
you were here you you were here doing a
different job and and for people to know
your story I was in a host role
and I was moving into a personality role
you were really interested in it but
because you were here and earned the
credibility and the right to stick your
name in the Hat you actually earned it
you step into that host role and then
how many years later before your
personality four years
and what's interesting Ken is four years
worth the wait yes
I think so
and part of that again I didn't raise my
hand to even be the host I put myself in
places where I went hey I'm gonna I want
to get on stage because I just love to
do that and people see that and they tap
you on the shoulder and go hey George
what do you think about this what's one
of those things that you did that was
outside of Ramsey I know the answer but
I want you to share it with people you
did some of that outside of Ramsey where
you just got yourself in a stage you're
on a stage and begin to confirm do I
want to do this oh absolutely give me an
example I did some outside hosting stuff
and I did whatever it took I once hosted
a this was an auto mechanics grand
reopening and I was on the flatbed of a
truck hosting this because I wanted to
get the Reps in I love that I once
hosted the swanny Day Festival where I
introduced balloon artists wow nobody's
listening to me they're out drinking
beer in their lawn chairs yeah but you
know what that but you know what we that
we wanted it that you want it yeah and I
have mad respect for anyone out there
who thinks what they're doing doesn't
matter right now because they don't see
the end game yeah and it's not the
Mountaintop they were hoping for yeah
but it's those reps that create the
opportunity down the line yeah it's
absolutely right you know everybody if
we walked on the street George you know
I've done man on the street stuff for
himself it's hilarious it's a lot of fun
if we walk down the street right now
with a mic and a camera and we said to
people are you willing to do what it
takes
to do what you love to wake up every day
and be excited and make good money doing
something you love they go absolutely
but then if we said are you willing to
wait as long as it takes I I dare say
the answer would be a lot different yes
oh absolutely it's patience that's the
game patience and diligence combined and
it's really freaking hard by the way
same 40 of the baby steps that's true
anything worth it in life yeah gazelle
intense but
waiting very difficult hey we're going
to keep taking your calls don't move
he's George Campbell I'm Ken Coleman
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show our
scripture of the day comes from Proverbs
11 24-25
one person gives freely yet gains even
more another withholds unduly but comes
to Poverty a generous person will
prosper whoever refreshes others will be
refreshed
Mark Twain once said to get the full
value of joy you must have someone to
divide it with
love that yeah that's good that's
speaking of generosity Ken speaking of
what a Segway I think we have the
greatest audience in the world a moment
just happens a moment out in the lobby
during the breaks if you ever come by
the way this is a great opportunity for
us to invite people to come see the show
can watch it in the lobby we have a
great crowd here today in the lobby and
and so we go out during the breaks a
couple times an hour and we say hi
and uh a lady comes up and she says a
couple months ago I was here and you
asked me if I brought any Skyline Chili
which is a which is a staple of
Cincinnati and so apparently when I met
her I said something like did you bring
me any chili because she's from
Cincinnati and she's like oh next time
well look at this if you watch it if
you're watching the show you can see
here uh this has been refrigerated
George feel that it's cool it's it's
ready to be warmed up I'm very impressed
because I know how difficult it is to
transport food yeah you know on Planes
Trains and Automobiles so she brought
she brought me the real deal James I
mean I even got the packet of crackers
wow uh I got some cheese to sprinkle on
it so before Building Wealth live
tonight at 7 pm Central load up on beans
is that the best idea though this is a
terrible idea as George said to her and
I quote he goes that's a lot of fiber
for a guy his age
I know George loves to poke photo Mage
but anyway thank you for the Skyline
Chili that was very sweet and I accept
all kinds of gifts I can be bought no
question about it all right back to the
phones we go triple eight eight two five
five two two five Taylor's in
Springfield Missouri Taylor how can we
help
hello Taylor
yes hello sorry cut to nothing I I guess
you might cut out
can I I was gonna call in for your
advice but after hearing that bit on
Chile I don't know if I'm so sure oh
what what what my advice is bad because
I like chili well Skyline Chili oh I got
a hater over in Missouri wow yeah Mr
Missouri taking shots at the Cincy folks
that's gonna cause a Ruckus I'm gonna
tell you something
it's good chili but anyway how can I
help you
well uh let's see I uh I'm a white
collar professional I guess you'd say I
have done basically the opposite of what
you suggested and I work from home I'm a
machine learning engineer
um
and make great money but the uh the job
isn't really doing it for me anymore and
so I've been looking at the trades and
I've pretty much settled on that I
wanting to be a plumber nice and yeah
well parts of it yes
um but what I uh what I'd like to know
is if you have advice first on how to
get a mindset right for making that trip
transition and then secondly and this
might be more of a of a George question
um that's going to represent a
significant pay cut as I go in for uh
you know working through the the
licensing how long will it be a pay cut
because I'm guessing there's a ladder
for you to get back up to where you are
and potentially if you and you're in
business do very very well well I would
have to own my own business to approach
where I am right now
um what are you making right now uh 150.
are you in a financial situation where
you have no debt and you you know got
great savings uh with an emergency fund
you've invested well what's that look
like great savings been crushing it with
retirement I've always been that kind of
max out my 401k good man how old are you
34. so you can absorb this without life
sucking correct
Yeah well yeah and I intentionally got a
uh I moved into a house with a low house
payment right okay so this is not a
financial issue this is a life
values quality of life issue and you're
just your Soul's being sucked into the
computer monitor sounds like to me and
you've now said I want to be a plumber
and I the reason I like this is because
I love seeing somebody go from White
Collar to what's called Blue Collar uh I
I I I I love the trades
um because the trades have been you know
just pooh-pooed for decades as a less
than uh lifestyle but the fact of the
matter is you can win in the trades you
can start a business and crush it and be
a job provider in the trades the the the
ceiling for you
um is really really high at 34.
um and so I the only confirmation
question I want to ask you is
what made you choose being a plumber
uh when I've done little bits of
Plumbing work I just really enjoyed it
so what do you enjoy about it well
working with my hands solving problems
both of those things I mean I love
problem solving there you go and not to
mention there's a real nice personal
um reward when you show up to the
Coleman house
and my wife meets you at the front door
and she goes thank God for you Kenza
Ken's just he's useless when it comes to
this stuff and we've got a clog over
here or we've got a leak and you are you
are a hero like you are her hero and you
are my hero in that moment
and there that's really rewarding isn't
it it is that's those are the parts of
my current job that I really find the
most satisfaction in is when I've helped
someone else do something so were you
calling for confirmation that this is
not a silly idea
you know I think probably I know you
were well Taylor I think the part that
is hard for you grappling with is going
from 150 to to 60 temporarily it doesn't
add up psychologically George no and
that's okay and it's honestly why we
recommend you do the Ramsay baby steps
because then you don't have to work for
that paycheck you can go work somewhere
for 75 and be fulfilled and still have a
great life and retire with dignity
so it's not about this number that has
to keep going up it's about your purpose
and you're stepping into that with great
clarity and in a great financial spot
our friends and family supportive of
this are they questioning you
uh you know they questioned about every
news I made over the last 10 years and
uh then they had to eat it so oh good oh
fantastic I like that so it feels like
that's not holding you back no yeah you
don't always end up being supportive
anyway I I like I said I'm gonna remind
you that I do think that there's no
ceiling for you or if there is a ceiling
it's really high for your earning
potential it's going to take some time
to build back but the quality of life
and and as George said and I gotta
actually I really want to applaud Taylor
George and you nailed it
having Financial Peace
allows you the margin to do this thing
to actually get up and not work for a
paycheck but to work on purpose this is
why I wrote the book from paycheck to
purpose this is the actual example of a
guy going hey I want to do something
that matters to me something that I
enjoy and he's not he's not strapped I
want to send him a copy of that book I
would like to do this because I think
it'll give him some clarity some
tactical things to work through and some
hope along this this Taylor that is uh
that is my gift to you you read it for
confirmation and just to give you that
confidence because they're going to be
some days and this is important to talk
about they're gonna be some days where
you begin to have some doubts uh and you
start to go
I can't believe I I took this big of a
pay cut or man this is really hard and I
want everybody to hear this George if
you are experiencing fear and doubt
right now
I want to encourage you
that the only people that experience
fear and doubt are the people that are
thinking about moving forward are the
people that are moving forward in other
words
the people who sit on the bleachers of
life watching everybody else live they
don't ever experience fear and doubt
they're trying not to choke on the
popcorn
and the rest of us are living and so if
you're experiencing fear and doubt that
is a good sign that you are longing for
something more that you are moving
towards something more and that's all it
is you you're never going to remove fear
and doubt you can overcome it George but
you cannot remove it and that and again
I'm going to tell you that also applies
not just to work and living on purpose
it applies to the baby steps to money to
getting out of debt there's going to be
some days in the middle of the baby
steps you're like I don't think we're
ever going to get through this and as
you step into it you gain a little bit
of confidence and a little bit more and
then you see the progress and all of a
sudden you get there it's amazing yeah
it works it works you know if you stay
with it if you stick with it you'll get
there but I guarantee this if you quit
you're never going to get there so do
not quit George Campbell I'm not going
to quit you pal appreciate that friends
for life there it is hey you want to
thank James and everybody in the booth
for keeping us on the air to you America
this is your show thank you for being
with us you you've got this and we're
gonna walk with you this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]